that was the big blow there to right
here and another big one
and down
former UFC champion Anthony Rumble
Johnson has died he was 38 years old
[Music]
TMZ reports the athlete died over the
weekend following an undisclosed illness
the Bellator MMA promotion company which
Anthony joined in 2021 shared the news
of his death on Twitter writing quote
the Bellator family is devastated by his
untimely passing and we send our
condolences to his family and friends
during this difficult time
[Music]
Anthony's UFC career began in 2007. he
competed in the welterweight
middleweight and light heavyweight
divisions and 17 out of his 23 career
wins were by knockout or TKO the points
early but now it looks like Johnson has
found his range and he continues to
Pepper Arlovski who seems to be a little
off bounds but continues to come back
with nice combinations fast forward 10
years and Anthony officially retired
from the sport in 2017. this is uh
something I have to do
for me
I love you all
I said I love you
I have to thank you all for
being there for me you know but after
only four years away he came out of
retirement and joined Bellator MMA in
his final fight in May 2021 he defeated
Jose Augusto here we go
Anthony Johnson hits the spot the
journey so far has been great my career
has been amazing
I'm very blessed to have the career that
I've excuse me had so far
um I look forward to seeing what happens
next but jump to September and Anthony
posted on Instagram he needed as many
prayers as I can get and was in a battle
noting it was not covet in May the
fighter celebrated getting good news
from his doctor his final post was on
October 21st Anthony is survived by his
two children
[Music]